each structure
in the protein data bank is assigned a
unique alphanumeric identifier
called the pdbid
this id appears on the first line of
search results
at rcsb.org
pdb 101 resources also linked to the
reference pdb structures
using the pdb id
enter the pdb id into the search bar on
rcsb.org
each protein in the pdb has a structure
summary page
which provides information about the
structure and
links to more resources
the macromolecule section provides
information
about the polymers or protein chains
making up
the structure this structure has two
identical chains
a and b the small molecule section
provides information about all ligands
and ions that interact with the polymers
this structure has two ligands and zinc
ions
in each of the chains clicking on the
small
molecule id allows us to access more
information about it
you can also explore the small molecule
in 3d
click on the 3d view tab to access the
3d viewer molestar
click on the frame icon to utilize the
full browser window for the 3d viewer
interface
the interface has three main panels
sequence panel
3d viewport and control panel the 3d
viewport
shows the 3d structure the sequence
panel
shows the sequence of the first polymer
components from the drop down menu you
can access additional components
such as ligands and ions the components
section
lists the type of components for the
structure polymer
ligands and ions it also lists how the
components are currently represented in
the viewport
polymer is shown as cartoon with each
chain
in different color ligands and ions are
shown in ball
and stick representation
often upon opening molestar some
structures will have a lot of water
molecules near the structure that are
not
relevant for your visualizations you can
hide them using the eye icon
or removing them using the trash bin
icon
use left mouse button to rotate model in
the 3d viewport
use the middle mouse button to zoom in
and out
use right mouse button to move the model
side to side click on the reload icon
to center the model in the viewport
the components panel lists the current
representation of components
to change the representation click the
three dots
icon choose add
representation and select the style
each component type needs to be changed
separately
to remove a representation click the
three dots icon
and go down to the representations list
use
the eye icon to hide and show the
representation
or use the trash bin icon to delete it
there are two ways to bring an amino
acid residue
into focus to observe its environment
you can click on a residue in the
sequence panel or
you can click on the residue of interest
in the viewport
either action will bring the residue
into focus
the label on the bottom displays
information about the element
that is currently in focus the component
section
now features the focus targets and its
surroundings
clicking outside of the structure
removes the focus
notice that you can add representations
to the focus target
and its surroundings by clicking the
three dots
icon when you scroll over a non-covalent
bond
the label on the bottom of the viewport
displays its type
and additional info the small molecules
can be brought into focus in similar way
you can click on the ligand of interest
in the viewport
you can click on a molecule of interest
in the sequence panel
in addition you can use the ligand
interaction button
from the structure summary page
in the component section top menu click
on the
sliders icon go to
non-covalent interactions unroll the
drop down menu
and adjust your settings
click the three dots icon next to the
component you want to change the color
for
unroll the set coloring drop down menu
there are many data-driven color themes
available
for example to apply rainbow coloring
choose
sequence id rainbow colors are applied
from the first
dark blue to last residue dark red
for each chain to see which color theme
is currently applied to the
representation
unroll its menu and click color theme
click the three dots icon next to the
component you want to change the color
for
unroll the set coloring drop down menu
and choose miscellaneous then
illustrative
then access the color theme for the
representation
click on the three dots icon next to the
color theme
then click the bookmark icon next to the
color list
to reveal the settings you can choose
different color themes
from there
this tutorial shows basic application of
the selections feature
if you would like to learn more advanced
applications
go to rcsb.org
and choose documentation from the top
menu
and access the documentation for
molestar
to enter the selection mode use the
arrow
icon the selection menu pops up on top
the initial selection level is one
residue
click on a residue to select it or
select it from the sequence panel
if an element is selected it is
highlighted in green
when you remove the cursor from it if
you want to select the chain
change the selection range to chain
click on the chain in the viewport to
select it
click on the paint brush icon to access
the color
settings choose the color and click
apply theme
click outside the chain to deselect it
use the x icon to exit selection mode
example
this structure has two chains you only
want to show
chain a enter the selection mode
change the selection range to chain
in the viewport select all elements
you want to delete use the
minus sign icon to delete the elements
delete the ions in the same way
exit the selection mode now
chain b is permanently deleted from the
mole star
session
example this structure has two chains
you want to use different molecular
representations
for each of the chains enter the
selection mode
change the selection range to chain
in the viewports select the polymer
chain
click on the cube icon to create a new
component
from the current selection click on
create component exit the selection mode
the new component is listed as custom
selection
in the components panel now you can add
representations
and change color themes for this
component individually
once you are done assigning colors and
representations
you can further refine your final image
using
the viewer rendering settings
you can change background or lighting
style
to save image click on the camera
shutter icon
use the crop icon to frame the molecule
be sure to adjust the resolution to your
needs
click the download button to save image
your image will be saved to the folder
set for downloads
in your browser settings
you